you
we have become a great role model not
simply in Afghanistan but also in the
United States and if I could use
Afghanistan as an example I'd love to
tell you a little story about one of the
girls in our communities she's about
nine years old I'm going to call her /
vana and after the Taliban for the first
time the girls could go to school but
Parvana father wouldn't allow her to go
and day after day pravana would watch
her friends going into school but she
had to stay home one day Parvana shows
up at school and I remember one of the
teachers approached her they were very
concerned because if Parvana zadar had
learned about this she might have been
killed and despite the fact of that she
could have been killed or the risks
involved she continued to come to school
one day she doesn't show up and every
one of the school was just sick about
this because they were worried what
would happen to this little girl well
the story is this she was with a family
that had never gone to school before
they were all illiterate her father had
received a letter from a relative in
Pakistan the father couldn't read it
well this little nine-year-old girl
steps up to the Father and says dad I
can read that letter and instead of
killing her he embraced her and that
story just had a ripple effect
throughout our entire community we went
from having 420 girls to over a thousand
we went from having eight teachers to
over 20 and then we went from having
that one little school to multiples
girls schools all over the region and so
for me I'm just utterly convinced that
it's not the US military that's going to
make changes in these countries it's
these nine-year-old little girls who are
so convicted about the importance of
education that they're literally willing
to risk their lives in order to make
this work
well right now we have we support 20,000
kids in Afghanistan my hope is that this
will cause a ripple effect throughout
that entire part of the nation one of
the interesting things about the area
where I'm working is that it is a
melting pot of multiple ethnic groups
religious practices and so our feeling
is that if we can make a difference in
this part of the country it will
reverberate in other parts but the other
legacy that I am very excited about is
what's happened here in the United
States my hope wasn't simply to build
structures it's to build relationships
to build relationships between our
countries and so what I've been seeing
is that when we first went in they
didn't know who we were what our
interests were but today if you go into
the classes there's a real interest in
getting to know America they like
Americans in fact I think many of them
would like to come here but what I've
also seen is that many of the kids here
in America are learning about another
culture after nine eleven I was very
much affected by protests that were held
around the world I remember one in
particular there's a sign held by a
pakistani protester and it says
americans think why are you hated all
over the world well that was something
that really struck me and having lived
extensively in the developing world I
wasn't necessarily surprised by what
happened at 911 but I wanted to go into
the communities and to teach people
about poverty what was causing terrorism
why would people be willing to become a
martyr and do this so I started this
project in the United States to build
schools for kids but instead of going
out to foundations and just getting
large sums of money I went to school
kids and I asked them to raise fifty
cents a week for 10 weeks and to
contribute to the schools in Afghanistan
what I found was that these kids became
empowered and they might have raised
five dollars but then many of them went
out and they raked leaves and they mowed
lawns and they sold
cakes and they did just about everything
you can imagine to help kids on the
other side of the world and today the
legacy is that many of these kids are
continuing their work albeit in the
Congo or Bolivia to help other kids and
even a couple months ago I went to
Washington DC and I had a neighbor with
me who was a high schooler and she had
gone to Congress with me to meet with
members of Congress and to talk about
the importance of educating kids in the
developing world so to me I've my hope
is that these communities these kids now
have a bigger understanding of the world
and that they're willing to participate
more fully
oh we have many challenges over there
one of the biggest is it's not simply
sufficient having a structure I need to
have educated teachers who have training
and that is a big short fall within
Afghanistan we also lack text books
supplies so virtually every sort of
system that we have here in the United
States is missing in that part of the
light
you